>> Harris: THEY SAY IT'S NOT A
LIE, IT'S THE COVER-UP THAT GETS
YOU IN TROUBLE.
THIS TIME MAYBE IT'S BOTH.
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY PETE
BUTTIGIEG WAS ON VACATION IN
PORTUGAL DURING CRITICAL TALKS
TO AVOID THE NATIONAL RAIL
STRIKE EARLIER THIS YEAR.
DURING THAT FOREIGN TRIP HE
POSTED A VIDEO.
IT SUGGESTED HE WAS ACTUALLY AT
AN AIRPORT IN THE UNITED STATES
DURING THOSE RAIL DEAL
NEGOTIATIONS.
YOU KNOW, TALKING SHOP.
WATCH.
>> THIS SUMMER TOO MANY FLIGHTS
HAVE BEEN DELAYED OR CANCELED.
TODAY WE'RE LAUNCHING THE
AIRLINE CUSTOMER SERVICE
DASHBOARD.
GO TO OUR WEBSITE AND COMPARE
AIRLINE PRACTICES IN ONE PLACE.
GIVES AMERICANS ON WHAT THE
AIRLINES WILL PROVIDE.
>> Harris: WE WON'T NEED A
DASHBOARD.
A SPOKESPERSON FOR THE
DEPARTMENT NOW SAYS HE WAS
TRAVELING ON PERSONAL TIME BUT
REMAINED ENGAGED ON URGENT
ISSUES WHILE AWAY LIKE THE BABY
FORMULA CRISIS, SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS.
ABSENT.
JIMMY FAILLA HOST OF FOX ACROSS
AMERICA ON FOX NEWS RADIO.
>> I DON'T WANT TO BAG TOO HARD.
IF MY VACATION PHOTOS LEAKED I
WOULD HAVE A BIG PROBLEM.
THIS IS THE ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC
ETHOS.
EMPHASIZE PERCEPTION OVER
REALITY.
THE PERCEPTION THEY'RE GOING
FOR.
YOUR TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY
WILL STOP AT NOTHING TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM.
REALITY.
HE WILL STOP AT A SWIM-UP BAR
AND HAVE A COUPLE OF DRINKS.
WHO IS WITH ME?
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE HAPPEN.
>> Harris: HE COULD HAVE JUST
SAID I'M TRAVELING RIGHT NOW ON
MY WAY FOR WHATEVER IT IS.
WE'RE NOT ASKING HIM TO GIVE US
DELICIOUS DETAILS OF HIS
PERSONAL LIFE.
JUST A LITTLE TRANSPARENCY.
>> WHEN WE WERE IN SUCH A
SITUATION LIKE THE RAIL STRIKE
YOU WOULD LIKE THEM TO BE
FORTHRIGHT BUT ALWAYS THE
HUSTLE.
>> Harris: OR TRAVEL BY TRAIN.
A NEW OP-ED ARGUES THE GOP
SHOULD BRING GENDER BACK TO THE
HOUSE ARGUING THE NEW MAJORITY
CAN DO THE DEMOCRATS LINGUISTIC
VANDALIS
VANDALISM.
IT MANDATES NO GENDER-INCLUSIVE
LANGUAGE CANNOT BE USED.
REPLACING WORDS FATHER, MOTHER,
SON, DAUGHTER, WITH NEUTRAL
VERSIONS, PARENT, CHILD,
SIBLING, ETC.
>> THIS INFURIATES ME FOR REAL
AND I WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND
WHY.
WHEN WE DEGENDER OUR LANGUAGE WE
DEMONIZE GENDER AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF IT AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF GENDER
DIFFERENCES, OKAY?
WE'RE NOT DOING THIS IN THE NAME
OF TOLERANCE AND INCLUSION.
THAT'S WHAT THEY TELL YOU.
WE ARE ERASING PEOPLE.
THAT'S NOT INCLUDING MEN AND
WOMEN.
THAT'S NOT CELEBRATING THE
UNIQUE BIOLOGICAL
CHARACTERISTICS THEY POSSESS.
WOMEN CAN GIVE BIRTH.
UNIQUE TO THEM AND AMAZING.
MEN CAN GET THROUGH A HOLIDAY
SEASON WITHOUT FORCING PEOPLE TO
WATCH LOVE ACTUALLY.
IT SHOULD BE CELEBRATED.
>> Harris: TONY HAS TO WATCH IT
TWICE THIS YEAR.
DEMOCRATS GOING AFTER
CONGRESSWOMAN KATIE PORTER FOR
HER TAKE ON THE WORD PEDOPHILE.
SHE SAID THIS.
>> THE GROOMER NARRATIVE IS AN
AGE-OLD LIE TO POSITION LGBTQ
PLUS PEOPLE AS A THREAT.
THE ALLEGATION OF GROOMER AND
PEDOPHILE IS ALLEGING THAT A
PERSON IS CRIMINAL SOMEHOW
ENGAGED IN CRIMINAL ACTS MERELY
BECAUSE OF THEIR IDENTITY.
THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND
SEXUAL IDENTITY.
>> Harris: IF WE CALL CRIMINALS
A PEDOPHILE WE NOW HAVE OFFENDED
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO ARE
PEDOPHILES?
I DON'T CARE.
YOU ARE A PEDOPHILE.
>> SHE IS A DOPE.
UNDERSTAND CERTAIN WORDS CARRY A
STIGMA BECAUSE IT'S PART OF THE
DETERRENT.
>> Harris: AND THEY'RE ALSO
CRIMINALS.
>> IN HER WORLDVIEW AN ARSONIST
IS A FIRE ENTHUSEIST WE'RE
DEMONSTRATING MORE EMPATHY.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
PEDOPHILES.
THEY ARE DESTROYING THE LIVES OF
CHILDREN.
HOW DARE ANYONE GO TO BAT FOR
THE PEDOPHILE OVER THE VICTIM,
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE AND IT IS
DISGUSTING.
>> Harris: SO WHEN SOMEONE IS
THE SHOOTER IN A STORY WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO CALL THAT --
>> PEOPLE WILL BE UPSET WITH
THEM.
>> Harris: WHAT WOULD WE CALL
THEM, A PERSON WITH A GUN WHO
HAD THE INTENTION TO FIRE IT ON
A TUESDAY?
>> THAT'S WHAT I MEAN.
IT'S STRAIGHT INSANITY.
THIS IS THE WORLD WE'RE LIVING
IN.
>> Harris: I DON'T WANT TO
HUMANIZE SOMEONE.
>> THE VICTIMS DESERVE OUR
EMPATHY.
>> Harris: SHE SAYS WE'RE
GROOMING PEOPLE.
>> THE GROOMER, OKAY, THE
DEMOCRATS ADVANCED LEGISLATION
BY TELLING YOU THAT ANYONE WHO
OPPOSES THAT EXTREME LEGISLATION
IS HATEFUL AND TRYING TO INVOKE
VIOLENCE OR AN ATTACK BECAUSE
IT'S HOW THEY STIFLE DEBATE.
IT IS SO LAZY TO SAY GROOMER IS
SPECIFIC TO THE LGBTQ PLUS CROWD
BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE ARE
STRAIGHT MEN WHO ARE GROOMERS.
HAS ANYONE LISTENED TO AN R.
KELLY ALBUM OR GOOGLED JEFFREY
EPSTEIN.
THE HUSTLE.
THEY CHARACTER TO EMOTIONAL AND
INTELLECTUAL LAZINESS BUT HAVE